well brie i mean it it is a big deal in
the fact that this is the you're the
first woman to helm her own marvel film
2019 i can't believe we're still saying
first but we are
yeah have you taken all that in digested
it
like let it sink no it doesn't it just
doesn't feel
good to think about i don't think it's
helpful to the work i don't think it's
helpful to my brain to think about that
and it also just feels like a little
sensational in that
there's a lot of female characters in
the marvel universe already i
i don't you know i understand like and i
want to own the fact that there is some
historical merit to it
but i also just don't want to i don't
want to negate the work that has already
been done before
by the way you were in singapore with
jimmy right did you fall in love with
her during crazy which ages like the
rest of us
and like re-obsessed with her before i
already worked with her
so i i knew her before i'd already
fallen in love with her
so it was just exciting to see her in
this completely different role in crazy
rich asians and then in singapore
we were staying at the hotel that you
see at the end of the movie
so we had a cocktail together in that
same area and then she took me to
eat street food in that same spot that's
in the movie no yeah so i had the full
experience
with gemma so you love the film as much
as the rest of us because i'm happy i
saw it opening weekend i was in the
front row
it was so it was sold out i just hit the
front row it was awesome i love that
um you know this film too it made me as
a woman i do have to say it made me feel
good watching it
i just felt good like i felt a bit
empowered and felt a bit emboldened
what makes you feel empowered not just
in the movie but
in life yeah you know recently it's come
from getting strong and training and
just getting to feel more
i don't know in my body martial arts has
really empowered me quite a bit
and i think it's something that i'll
continue to learn and grow with for the
rest of my life
i think it's just nice to i've been
acting my whole life to find something
else that i think will be a practice of
mine that i'll keep with
for the rest of my time here is kind of
cool can you still pull a jeep
could i push one push a jeep yeah you
pushed it and pulled it well here's the
thing i've been on this presto i've been
sitting down a lot
so give me a couple weeks just to like
turn all my muscles back on yeah i could
do it
i love that see i like her yes i can
she said not i don't know yes i can i
i'm very competitive so you give me a
challenge i'm gonna take it do you
remember though
that day three years ago when they
announced you at comic-con like when you
had that moment yeah i think i
feel like around this you know i've had
a lot of long playing flights in my
little pod by myself to just reflect on
my life and go like how did i get here
what is happening to me
and it is moments like that that i think
about it's also like
all of the auditions that i was rejected
at that i think about
you know because i think on these press
tours it's an exciting time
it's a time that we're talking about
like positive things and you see a movie
that's a finished product that has all
of my best takes in it but we don't talk
about
all of the times that i hit the floor
and had to get back up again
we saw that in the movie in some way
shape or form which i thought was cool
too seeing the trajectory of her
and how she kind of is finding herself
and where that
oomph comes from exactly and whatever
that is i think
everybody has their own reasons for
getting back up um
i've just always had that thing inside
of me where i just i'm not going to give
up i'm not going to roll over and so it
feels really good to stand here today
and to go
really honestly all of that stuff every
time i hit the floor and we can say that
that
is with auditions roles i didn't get
dudes that didn't like me and i can also
say that about the physical training of
this movie of like doing wire work
stunts where i
missed my feet slipped and fell and hit
the ground that all that stuff ended up
in this movie and is a huge part of
what this film really is so i feel like
it embodies what it what it says
it is i know that you you know you want
to
be kind of even keeled about the fact
that you are the first woman to helm her
own solo marvel movie but also captain
marvel
is the most powerful person in the
marvel universe
i mean that is a bit of a you know a way
to take over now that i like
that i won't try to be chilly i hear you
i'm very into being the strongest i hear
you yeah
the dynamic between you and sam that one
who's coming over here now
is pretty special it's pretty special
it's my family
she said you're her family friend
i told you
did you know sam jackson could carry a
tune yes
i've always known that he's always
singing he's always singing yes
i feel like there was a lot of singing
happening on kong what is there
yeah what is his best song what do you
what have you heard him
i feel like you're seeing mostly oldies
okay he doesn't want me to talk about it
oh well
i'll tell you what i was saying i sing a
lot of cats on like a set of cops did
you
yeah i did well my i think one of my
favorite videos in the past month that
i've seen is you and twitch
doing your jitterbugs yeah i mean you do
love to dance and that's the woman after
my own heart
it's a new thing for me and really all
of that came from the training and
martial arts and boxing
and really going like it feels good to
own my body it feels good to be in it
and i wonder what else i can do if i can
dead lift 225 pounds maybe i can dance i
love that
what's your that's my jam song right now
what's your go-to
i've been listening to the ariana grande
album like is it
dope on loop in the maggie rogers album
those two have been
like the only thing i'm listening to
right now i didn't and i feel a little
ashamed that i
was surprised i love the ariana album so
much but it's fire i
love it i love every single song came
into it
i love it i really love it and i think
it's so honest and powerful
and it's fun to sing there's great dance
songs great ballets
i love ariana well we love you and we
love this movie and i'm just
so happy for you i really i like when
good things happen